that is the steamy photo that katherine
heigl posted to tease a secret project
with her husband Josh Kelly didn't take
long for word to spread that they were
working on a new music video together
but only our sofa shal AC was there on
the set as the couple got down to
business
we build something beautiful
I still want
there was Catherine's idea that she
stripped down and nothing but white
lingerie I mean for her directorial
debut she's definitely making a
statement now pay real close attention
to the words of the song because you get
total insight into their marriage
pretty much accurately based on an
argument and a time in our marriage that
we were really struggling it was a
pretty big fight but it was a good one
and it was a healthy one
it wasn't anything big it wasn't like no
one cheated no one did anything that was
just an absolute game ender it was just
we were starting to forget that we were
supposed to be on each other's side and
I won't lie there was you know play a
little bit too much genitive going on
and so then the fights escalate and the
miscommunication and hurt feelings Josh
wrote it's your move as sort of his
post-fight apology our on set exclusive
is kind of a full circle moment since
these two met on a music video set
Catherine walked in one and a hookup
with the cute lead singer I remember
showing up like who I'm single like I've
never dated a musician this could be fun
I was you know excited to meet him and
he was like hey thanks for coming out I
appreciate you being here we're gonna
have a fun day and I thought okay I
guess this isn't going to happen there
will be no flirting or fun or maybe a
you makeout session later like this
guy's not interested but it just as the
day went on I can kiss nerves kind of
lessons we just started dating that day
never stopped yeah it worked out and we
still together make that 11 years of
together and then throw in the two
adorable daughters seven-year-old naeli
and almost four year old Adelaide the
family's kind of anti Hollywood living
on a farm in Utah but they treat us to
glimpses of cuteness on Instagram
little singer it's just one dude and a
ton of chick and way on ever you can
watch the full video exclusively on our
website ET online.com and you can
pre-order Josh's album new Lane Road
right now it drops on April 22nd